[Music]
welcome to a Happy New Year's edition of
every damn day we hope whatever times on
your end that you're having a great end
of the year and that you're getting
excited for a fun New Year's Eve we're
doing a special show where we're gonna
all tell you what our New Year's
resolutions are but there's a little
twist to make sure that we stick to them
Jordan why don't you explain what we're
doing so today we're doing a high-stakes
a New Year's resolution where if you
don't do the thing that you say you're
gonna do you're gonna put money into
something that you don't want to put
money into a punishment a punishment
yes anti charity so to get things
started Ryan what what is your new
year's resolution my new year's
resolution is to become a new face at
the Just for Laughs Montreal Comedy
Festival 2019 look at this image we made
oh wow Ryan that's gonna be you what's
your punishment what's your punishment
what's your anti charity is Hannah
Dickens I do not become a new face at
the Montreal Comedy Festival this year I
will give Hannah Dickinson $25 Wow 25
big 25 met Jordan still owes her please
blacklist
Oh cheers to you Ryan I believe that
you'll be able to do it and what's a big
step that you're gonna take today to get
closer to this I'm gonna say something
funny on this show a Hanabi Jeff singer
and the one who books jester laughs yeah
yes and please welcome to the stage
everybody Ryan back he's auditioning for
a fellas new faces show him your love
thanks I got this my dog you know it's
my dog here this is Laila your shirt's
weird I wouldn't wear this shirt for the
audition but my girlfriend's name is
Grace and my dog's name is Lily and
people get that confused all the time
which is a lot of fun for me right
because I'm like oh I got to get home
and make dinner for Lily
people like wow that's so romantic
I don't know she just eats it off the
floor maybe 2020 what is your resolution
gonna be you know naturally mine is
blank decided no I haven't decided
because I'm very torn because I either I
want to consistently volunteer to
charity or I want to have abs I mean
both are probably never gonna have that
they're both insurmountable yeah one
would make me feel good and one would
make me feel other people yeah right
don't want to give back or do I want to
take in oh my god what should we define
regularly at a charity it's like once a
week
wow that's a lot yeah well yeah you
could say very liberal Cox to get abs
you would probably have to work out more
than once a week times a week to get abs
yeah I work every day seven times a week
and my body is discussing abs are made
in the kitchen and well you better go
with the charity I've seen Hannah you
try to do acts of physicality before and
the show actually you told us that you
could do the worm and I believe we gave
you a week to go practice it and you
came back and this is what you did
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so with that you think you can really
get those abs here we come Boys and
Girls Club what she's gonna make a
choice okay imagine going to a charity
and you have to talk to those people
that every week once a month is
regularly once a month that's fine I
would every once a month probably
something different like go see movies
all the time I am going to get what is
your punishment gonna be if you don't
get ads I am going to get a subscription
to hustler and since my parents house
under my name yeah we'll do a mid-year
check-in to make sure that everyone's on
target I don't I just didn't have them
at one point of the year I can't we get
a photo of you with ABS that is not
photo shot on the show if I get abs I
will be naked I will be wearing with the
charity okay a bikini I'll be like you
can wear that and then go to a charity
why what's your resolution 19 mine is
that I will post one video week to
YouTube and post one post per day to
Instagram this is for 365 days every day
so 52 videos to videos and 365 posts on
on Instagram no but one a day not 365
posts one a day one a day one every day
oh my god middle day you can't post not
a good idea is that even advisable to
post that much well Jake Paul I'm taking
his social how to become famous on
social media course it was faster
collars day six dogs what I masturbate
to when I go to bed
and he says post one a day even more
Jake Paul is Logan Paul's younger
brother and he is a comedian is how he
sucked describes just like Jordan just
like me oh he has millions millions of
followers and my handle is at Jordy
pizza so leave it up on the screen for
the entirety of the rest of the video if
you point that direction I thought they
would think there's a world where it's
gonna be over there is a minority
reporting it out of the screen and
Jordan what is your punishment okay what
is your anti charity yeah so I am going
to get a tattoo of the Paul Brothers my
Bros underneath yes where on your body
you're gonna get it I'm thinking like
right here Wow like sort of a classic
mom thing it's so like right there I
didn't really do this sad well whatever
happened to throw it in I believe in you
cheers to Joy here's the Jordan cheers
the Hannah getting shredded and cheers
baby water my resolution for 2019 is
that I'm gonna run a 100-mile race so
I'm gonna run a hundred miles all at
once why don't you just get like
waterboarded yeah
and my big step is that I already signed
up for it
Wow it costs $300 whoa
so I'm signed up for a 100-mile race on
November 2nd 2019 today like you don't
sleep and I'm also gonna run a 50-mile
race in August as preparation on the way
there I've already signed up for that
one too Oh we'll do a mid-year check-in
around August or September to make sure
everyone's on track and see if anyone
has already failed where is this that
one is in California it's good to know
what state you're gonna die
and the date training yeah afterwards oh
yeah yeah people people end up power
hiking a lot of them and my my anti
charity my punishment is that if I don't
do this if you don't complete it or if
you don't do it mi-jin I thought about
you're gonna complete this thing I guess
I have to complete it you have to
complete it yeah so if I don't complete
the 100 mile race so if I don't make the
cutoff then I have to buy a 489 dollar
gift certificate to Arby's and eat that
food $500 and you know why 489 no
because it's the funniest number do you
know why it's the funniest number cuz of
this because it's 420 plus 69
mathematically the funniest number yeah
I agree you know like that was such an
unfunny way to make those two numbers
just singers a jerk somebody jester your
hat on you know I'm very critical of the
comedy but I do love you and please pick
me for a new faces all right thanks for
spending your New Year's Eve with us
follow along to see if everyone meets
their goals especially Jordan Mendoza
you might be able to see him fail first
we hope you have a happy and safe night
tonight and all of your wildest dreams
come true in 2019 and beyond Happy New
Year everybody
Happy New Year no you said oh wow from
the bottle interesting take
[Music]
you